Surveillance video catches
a Delhi street quarter
to nine on Sunday evening.
What the man in blue is about to
do is too violent to be shown
in the next moments.
A 16 year old girl's life is taken.
Stabbed and bludgeoned with a rock
against the wall of her house.
Witnesses pass by, but no one intervenes.
Violence against women is so pervasive
in India
that a young girl can be stabbed
in public
in a busy neighborhood
against the wall of a home.
The killing of this teenage
girl is the latest
in a long line of violent crimes
against women in India.
This time it's on film,
shared rapidly online, and it has gripped
the nation.
The man in blue has been arrested
for the murder
and named by police simply as Sahil.
Police say the two were in a relationship
and had an argument shortly
before the killing.
The family pleading for justice,
even as across
India demands grew to do more
to protect women
and punish their male attackers.
But public anger is no comfort
to families
stricken by grief
at the loss of their child
within the next.
I feel lifeless
I miss her so much.
She was such a good child.
What to do
Her mother, inconsolable
as a daughter, was cremated Monday near
she went to the bazaar to buy some things
and then went to celebrate
a friend's birthday.
She had gone to buy some new sandals
for the birthday.
The sandals are now
at the police station.
Life continues
in this poor neighborhood
in north west Delhi.
Investigators have marked a small cross
in the place
where the young girl was killed.
One more place where women aren't safe
from men.
Balika. CNN, New Delhi.